you talk about something called the
bully and the butterfly your committee
as it relates to meeting characters yes
another big topic and i think
karen i think we talked about this in
the last interview
many many years ago okay my memories no
no no no that's
no that's okay this this has to do with
the committee
now the committee i'll explain um
in fact in the interrogation that we
just did
there was the committee but i'll explain
how that works
the um the term committee the way
we use it stan represents
all the voices in your head so all the
voices in your head karen
or david heads david's head else's
there's many voices in there
and as you know these voices in our
heads that we all have
we talk to them they talk to us they
criticize us they praise
us they advise us or whatever they get
in the way sometimes
and there are a lot of them that's why i
call it the committee
because i feel like there's a lot in my
head i feel like there's a lot of these
voices
and they are sometimes in session
discussing something
so the voices in the head of us as
humans are very important because i feel
like
my committee your committee david's or
else's committee
or i'll go back to your committee for
karen your committee
knows everything about you everything
even stuff that nobody else knows it's
in there
somewhere yeah so when you think about
the fact that we have all these voices
in our head and these voices know
everything about us and
each voice in our head has different
opinions about that subject or that
topic or any subject or any topic
this is a very rich territory inside any
human being
but then think about a character a
character in a movie
a character like jill jill has a
committee
and if you could get into her committee
if you could
visit her committee you would know more
about jill
but the problem is in screenplays and
most stories that were plays however
they were written
we are given no information at all about
the committee inside a character
nothing we know what the character does
we know what the character says
we know what the character expels she
expresses herself what she wants what
her needs are
we get a little idea of what she's
afraid of on all that but we really
don't know what's going on
inside her head okay
because inside her head inside jill's
head
are all of these voices
now what is it the butt butterfly and
the and the bully
the bully the bully and the butterfly
yeah
colin you're committing yeah the bully
now what i just did
with you with jill and that was mostly
the bully the bully that there's a voice
inside jill's head which is saying
get out get out get out get out get out
what you ex kept trying to hold on to
was another voice this will work this
will work
if i give him time you're trying that's
the butterfly
if you're trying to hold on sometimes
there were a couple of times when i was
talking to you i would support the
butterfly
but then i would go back to the bully so
the thing is there's a
war going on inside
the committee there's a war going on
inside
every one of our committees it's ju it's
it's chaos in there
so the interrogation is giving voice
to all of those voices so every time i
i can attack you about something i can
praise you about something
those are two different voices of the
committee
inside jill's head and jill
by jill you as voicing jill
responding to those voices of her
committee
every time you respond jill gets formed
a little bit more
a little bit more a little bit more so
jill is getting
formed by forming the committee
not by telling the actress or the writer
who jill
is but by forming jill
through the an interrogation process
and then are they also forming who jack
is
same thing because they're confronting
her on these different things
well i mean by confronting well we're
forming
yes we're forming jill's point of view
of jack
now if i interrogate jack or if i
interrogate you as
jack or interrogate somebody else as
jack
it won't be the same as jill jack has
his point of view jack has his
jack has his committee
his committees that says you know she
should take care of me this
is what the you know she's the wife i'm
just making it up i don't know
but he will have his committee that
justifies his behavior
or questions his behavior he's got
a different committee but it's also in
chaos so these committees are in chaos
and it's building a character from deep
deep
inside the character where quite
respectfully to writers
and actors writers and actors will
create the character from
outside writers will design a character
you design this character
actors will look at a script and go okay
oh no i
i can design a character that will do
those things that are in the script
but that's not really developing the
character at all that's really
creating sort of like a puppet that will
do the things that are demanded in the
script
the thing is what's going on inside that
character
that causes him or her to do those
things in the script
that's what you have to build and that
has to be built
from way deep inside not on the outside
so when someone's writing a script and
we're not connecting to the character
is that because it's almost a puppet it
could be
it could be a two-dimensional character
yep a puppet who's just
doing i mean we've all seen films or
plays or whatever
where our television where we go
well the only reason that character is
doing that is because
the writer needs them to do that right
so
it's not the character it's the writer
pulling strings
to get the character to do that so that
the story will work out
that happens too often
and why do you think this this meeting
their characters and the interrogation
why do you think it just
puts you in a different mindset because
i'm already in a different mindset about
a character that
i just kind of like came up with and
i've been thinking about for years but
never really did anything with
so i'm not totally invested but now like
i feel like that person is real
from just sitting here with you for that
10 to 15 minute span
why do you think it works what is it
that happens i think
part of the reason it's a great question
i think part of the reason it works
um for both writers and actors but we'll
talk about writers for a second
is because that's sort of the situation
you're in with jill
is suddenly there's a respect for
another human being
you feel like there's another human
being existing who's jill
and i've met her or there's these other
human beings of these characters that i
thought i created
i've met them in person and i now
i have an obligation to them
as the writer to honor them
not i have a task of creating them
i have a task of honoring them and who
they are and what that relationship is
so i think there's a there's a um a
different respect
and i think the same thing happens for
actors when they've been interrogated
they
feel they've had this experience of this
character that lives inside them and
still it's like i need to honor this
this person there is there is another
person
it's not just me acting so acting sort
of goes away
yeah i don't know if you saw joker but
yeah if you saw
the way joaquin phoenix approached the
character of arthur fleck i mean
whether you want to say it was a
terrible human being
but you there were just so many moments
where you had at least for me as a
viewer
i had so much empathy yeah for that
character and i think that's through
joaquin's you know treating him it's
just
he was a real yeah it's his total
immersion yeah
i mean it's an extraordinary performance
absolutely and his total
immersion into that
tortured human being and it's
interesting because he ends up becoming
he ends up doing horrible things evil
things
killing people and yet i have empathy
for him because he's so
tortured he's so you know it's i mean
that's an extraordinary achievement
absolutely and the same with renee
zellweger as uh judy yeah
garland yep same thing you know
especially from just the opening scene
just
showing up at the hotel with the kids
and then
not knowing if she could stay or not and
just yeah
this like fragility but then this like
you know
on stage persona it was just
seeing characters like that like you
just all time goes away yeah
you know and in that moment when you
were asking
about my character time went away and i
felt like i was hurt
good
you